Hey...
Hey is for horses!
Happy Freaky Friday!
Freaky, freaky, freaky.
Freaky, get freaky.
Hot dog, freaky, freaky, freaky.
I was listening to your stream in the background a few nights ago while cramming and today I'm proud to say I passed the test!
Let's go Ray!
Freaky, freaky, freaky, freaky, freaky.
I just played a freaky game and now I'm scared.
And I'm afraid to look around my room because what if something moves?
And then it's haunted but it's not haunted by me.
I don't like people, I don't like ghosts.
I wanna be by myself.
That's the song.
Oh wait, hold on.
Let me know how this sounds you guys.
It might sound fine, hold on.
This is what I was trying to fix earlier.
Do you hear this?
It might sound fine, if it's too much reverb I'll adjust it.
But you are a ghost.
Oh yeah, that's why I said haunted by someone else other than me!
Yeah, no?
Guys...
What's a freaky song to sing?
What's a freaky song?
I only did the impromptu karaoke because I was like...
Oh, the game is not very long.
I didn't know it would be so short, so I added this too.
Monster Mash.
It's not Halloween.
So excited for Phantom Thief, I will cheer my heart out.
Yeah!
I
just got my chicken and dill pickle white sauce calzone.
Pickle?
Sing some weird Al.
Solem, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Solem!
Happy birthday!
And last birthday Al, thank you for the birthday gift and thank you!
Weird Al has two, it shows me two Christmas songs.
The Night Santa Went Crazy, I don't know what that one is about.
But also Christmas at Ground Zero.
I don't know what that's also a parody of.
eBay, do I know that one?
Both classics.
Ground Zero, Metal Gear, Solid Snake.
Solid Snake welcome to membership.
Christmas at Ground Zero, but I don't know what it's parodying.
Do Friday, oh my gosh because it's Friday the 13th.
Here we go.
7am, waking up in the morning.
Gotta be fresh, gotta go downstairs.
Gotta have my bowl, gotta have my cereal.
Seeing everything, the time is going.
Ticking on and on, everybody's rushing.
Gotta get down to the bus stop.
Gotta catch my bus.
I see my friends, kicking in the front seat.
Sitting in the back seat.
Gotta make up my mind of which seat can I take.
It's Friday, Friday.
Gotta get down on Friday.
Everybody's looking forward to the weekend, weekend.
Friday,
looking forward to the week.
7.45, we're driving on the highway cruising so fast.
These are not the lyrics.
She has to tell herself to think about fun.
Sitting in the back seat.
Gotta make
up my mind of which seat can I take.
Today, it is Friday.
We, we, we, so excited.
We so excited.
Tomorrow is Saturday.
And Sunday comes afterwards.
It's like, this song is the original AI written lyric song, I believe.
It's Friday, Friday.
Gotta get down on Friday.
Everybody's looking forward to
the...
Party and party and yeah!
Fun, fun, fun, fun.
Friday, Friday.
Rebecca Black is still a musician.
She makes actually decent songs from what I've heard.
Not your best work to be honest.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
There's a bunch of us watching you off a phone in the park.
In the park, on the highway right now.
Okay, people in the park.
What, what, what would be a good song to sing?
No, I can't sing that song.
Oh, I was gonna sing a song.
What would be a good song to sing?
I was gonna sing a song, but it's actually part of the setlist.
A freaky song, but it's actually part of the setlist tomorrow.
That's why it's in my head right now.
The weirdest part about these lyrics is...
You expect the weekend, but after everyone is looking forward to it so much.
Do you think you can sing Baby Shark?
Baby Shark do do do do do do do Baby Shark do do do do do do do Baby Shark do do do do do do do Baby Shark Wow, look at all these grown people in the park.
And they're watching Cocomelon.
These grown ass men watching Cocomelon in the park.
Like freaks, why are they doing that?
Why don't they watch the news or something?
Oh, Cocomelon baby adults over here.
Everybody stay away from these freaks.
Everybody.
They're watching Cocomelon past the age of one.
Why are you shaving me though?
I wonder if there's any Cocomelon songs on here.
Do they have any of their own zero results?
Wait, Baby Shark.
Christmas Baby Shark?
Hold on.
Sing Lazy Town?
That's a good idea.
Baby Shark do do do do do do Baby Shark do do do do do do Baby Shark do do do do do do Baby Shark Mommy Shark do do do do do do Mommy Shark do do do do do do Mommy Shark do do do do do do Mommy Shark Daddy shark, do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do Is that a dog clothes?
Is that a dog clothes?
It's for you.
And...
Happy...
Merry...
Holidays...
Happy Holidays!
Grandpa Shark, are you ok?
Grandpa Shark.
Grandpa Shark is not gonna make it you guys.
Oh no, no, no, no more baby shark.
It's ok.
Guys, Grandpa Shark is on his last breath.
Oh, Grandpa Shark is... Grandpa Shark is seeing the light.
Grandpa Shark can only breathe out.
He doesn't breathe in.
Oh, what was it?
LazyTown.
I hope my request didn't end your stream.
Grandpa Shark is kinda doing it for me.
Ok, wait.
I love this song.
This is audio by the way.
I forgot to ask.
Now listen closely.
Here's a little lesson in trickery.
This is going down in history.
If you wanna be a villain number one, you have to chase a superhero on the run.
Just follow my moves and sneak around.
Be careful not to make a sound.
Shh, no, don't touch that.
Now look at this net that I just found.
When I say go, be ready to throw.
Go!
Throw on him, not me.
Let's try something else.
Now watch and learn.
Here's the deal.
Slip and slide on this banana peel.
What are you doing?
I forgot to do the...
I forgot to update the setlist.
You guys, is this the most...
Baby shark, Christmas.
This might be the most...
amazing setlist I've ever done.
This will be sure to bring in all the folks.
Can you do a song by the Wiggles?
Yeah.
I don't know a Skibbity.
There's a Skibbity song?
Fruit salad.
Yummy, yummy.
Let's make some fruit salad today.
Start to do it the healthy way.
Take all the fruit that you want to eat.
It's going to be a fruit salad treat.
The first step.
Peel your bananas.
The second step.
Toss in some grapes.
The third step.
Chop up some apples.
Chop up some melons and put them on your plate.
Now you've made it, it's time to eat.
It tastes so good that you just can't beat it.
Give everyone a plate and a spoon.
We'll all be eating it very soon.
The first step.
Eat up the banana.
The second step.
Eat up some grapes.
The third step.
Eat up some apples.
Eat the melons, now there's nothing on your plate.
Now we've had our fruit salad today.
It's time to put the scraps away.
Wash the bowls and wash the spoon.
Let's do it all again real soon.
Why is this song so long?
Yummy, yummy.
Fruit salad.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Together!
Yummy, yummy.
Fruit salad.
That was fruit salad.
I also...
I saw your super chat.
I don't know VeggieTales songs.
Fruit salad.
Yummy, yummy.
Good.
Well, you know.
Next therapy session is gonna be interesting.
Big red car.
I don't think I know that one.
Had my birthday in November, but did not attend to watch the stream before now.
Can I still have a birthday song?
Ffff....
Ffff...
OK.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Gray is not there.
Very light birthday.
To you.
Good evening.
Keep being awesome.
Thank you.
Oh, so PandraDrag...
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Whole request, do no clint ad songs.
I don't know if I was gonna do it.
I could do JP today.
Maybe.
If I can find them.
Put that on the set list.
What's a freaky song?
Atabama necromancy.
I sang that for Halloween.
Let's see.
Wait, hold on.
I know one.
Let's see.
This is a kind of freaky song.
What's the duck song?
I don't know that one.
Creep by Radiohead except it's freaky.
Don't you disrespect me little man.
Don't you derogate or deride.
You're in my world now, not your world.
And I've got friends on the other side.
He's got friends on the other side.
That's an echo, gentlemen.
Just a little thing we have here in Louisiana.
A little parlor trick, don't worry.
Sit down at my table.
Put your minds at ease.
If you relax, it will enable me to do anything I please.
I can read your future.
I can change it around some too.
I'll look deep into your heart and soul.
You do have a soul, don't you, Wisp?
Make your wildest dreams come true.
I've got voodoo, I've got voodoo.
I've got things I ain't even tried.
And I've got friends on the other side.
I've got human friends on the other side.
The cards, the cards, the cards will tell.
The past, the present, and the future as well.
The cards, the cards.
Just take three.
Take a little trip into your future with me.
Now you, young man, are from across the sea.
You come from two long lines of royalty.
I'm a royal myself on my mother's side.
Your lifestyle's high, but your funds are low.
You need to marry little honey because daddy got low.
Mom and dad cut you off, huh, playboy?
You guys wish, right?
You just want to be free, hop from place to place.
But freedom takes green.
It's the green, it's the green, it's the green you need.
And when I look into your future, it's the green that I see.
You, little man, I won't waste much time.
You've been pushed around all your life.
You've been pushed around by your mother and your sister and your brother.
And if you was married, you'd be pushed around by your wife.
But in your future, the you I see is exactly the man you always wanted to be.
Shake my hand.
Got my wisps?
Won't you shake a poor sinner's hand?
Yes!
Are you ready?
Transformation Central!
Reformation Central!
Can you feel my gratification?
You're changing, you're changing, all right.
I hope you're satisfied.
But if you win, don't blame me.
You can blame my friends on the other side.
My favorite Disney song by my favorite YouTuber.
Let's go!
Thanks for the pink!
That was...also who the hell said...
Thank goodness I missed the songs that I hate.
How do you hate fruit salad?
And we are number one!
We are number one, it's the absolute most goated song ever.
What was that?
Oh, friends on the other side.
It's the green, it's the green.
What?
Is my mic OK?
I hear it going...I hear it like peaking.
I'll turn it down.
Maybe I'll just hold my mic instead.
Like I'm holding an actual mic.
I'm holding my mic now.
Well, these guys are holding it, but you know.
That was really close to me.
Love Mito's evil laugh.
See, like right there.
My mic is OK.
Anyway, thanks for the gift ad.
Do you know PPAP?
I have a pen.
I have an apple.
Apple pen.
I have a pen.
I have pineapple.
Pineapple pen.
Apple pen.
Don't worry, we'll sing some serious songs too.
Well, I say serious, but like...
Time Warp!
That's a good freaky song.
Time Warp.
It says duet.
Which is the right one?
There are so many versions.
I'll try.
Wait, let's see this one.
I'm in the US right now.
We'll be playing a car game tomorrow.
Oh my gosh, Mito!
Good luck!
Good luck, good luck!
OK, I'm the pen.
Wait, do I have to do both parts?
It's astounding.
Time is fleeting.
Madness takes its toll.
But listen closely.
Not very much longer.
I've got to keep control.
I remember
drinking.
Though the blackness would hit me.
And a voice would be calling.
Let's do the Time Warp.
Let's do the Time Warp again.
It's just a jump to the left.
And then a step to the right.
With your hands on your hips.
You bring your knees in tightness.
That really drives you insane.
Let's do the Time Warp again.
It's so dreamy.
Oh, fantasy, free me.
So you can't see me.
No, not at all.
In another dimension.
With voyeuristic intention.
Well secluded.
I see all.
With a bit of a mind flip.
And with a time flip.
And nothing can ever be the same.
You're spaced out on sensation.
Like you're under sedation.
Let's do the Time Warp.
Wait, you shook me up.
He took me by surprise.
He had a pick.
I felt a change.
Time
then.
It's just a jump to the left.
With your hands on your hips.
You bring your knees in tight.
But it's the pelvic.
Let's do the Time Warp.
Let's do the Time Warp again.
Freaky.
Time.
Warp.
I saw someone request this earlier.
Like I said, they don't have to be all freaky songs.
Freaky.
This one, right?
Whenever I see someone less fortunate than I.
Let's face it, who is it?
Less fortunate than I.
My tender heart tends to start to bleed.
And when someone needs a makeover, I simply have to take over.
I know, I know.
Exactly what they need.
And even in your case.
Though it's the toughest case I've yet to face.
Don't worry.
I'm determined to succeed.
Follow my lead.
And yes, indeed.
You will be popular.
You're gonna be popular.
I'll teach you the proper poise when you talk to boys.
Little ways to flirt and flounce.
I'll show you what shoes to wear.
How to fix your hair.
Everything that really counts to be popular.
I'll help you be popular.
You'll hang with the right cohorts.
You'll be good at sports.
Know the slang you've got to know.
So let's start.
Cause you've got a long way to go.
Don't be offended by my frank analysis.
Think of it as personality dialysis.
Now that I've chosen to become a pal, a sister, an advisor.
There's nobody wiser.
Not when it comes to popular.
I know about popular.
And with an assist from me.
To be who you'll be.
Instead of dreary who you were.
There's nothing that can stop you from becoming popular.
We're gonna make you popular.
When I see depressing creatures.
With unprepossessing features.
I remind them on their own behalf.
To think of celebrated heads of state.
Or specially great communicators.
Did they have brains or knowledge?
Don't make me laugh.
They were popular.
Please.
It's all about popular.
It's not about aptitude.
It's the way you're viewed.
So it's very shrewd to be.
Very, very popular.
Like me.
Oh my gosh.
Wisps.
Look at you.
You're beautiful.
I have to go.
Wow, that sounds sexy.
And though you protest.
Your disinterest.
I know clandestinely.
You're kinda gonna embarrass me from popularity.
You'll be popular.
Just not quite as popular.
As me.
They're watching you in a waffle house?
Wait, actually...
Don't do that.
You're supposed to fight at the waffle house.
Popular.
I know I'm all popular.
What's up fighting music?
Don't say break stuff.
I have to save my throat.
Hope you have fun at the concert too.
Thank you Panther.
Burno, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Dark of the night from Anastasia.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Wait, I know one song from Anastasia.
Actually I know a couple songs from Anastasia.
I am the tiger.
Oh that's a great one.
Fight!
Bloody.
Time took my chances.
Went the distance, now I'm back on my feet.
Just a man and his will to survive.
So many times it happened too fast.
You change your passion for glory.
Don't lose your grip on the dreams of the past.
You must fight just to keep them alive.
It's the eye of the tiger.
It's the thrill of the fight.
Rising up to the challenge of our rival.
And the last known survivor stalks his prey in the night.
And he's watching us all with the eye of the tiger.
Face to face, out in the heat.
Hanging tough, staying hungry.
Except you're at Waffle House, you should be eating.
We stack the odds till we take to the street.
For the kill with the skill to survive.
It's the eye of the tiger.
It's the thrill of the fight.
Rising up to the challenge of our rival.
And the last known survivor stalks his prey in the night.
And he's watching us all with the eye of the tiger.
Rising up, straight to the top.
Had the guts, got the glory.
Went the distance, now I'm not gonna stop.
Just a ghost, and with no will to survive.
It's the eye of the tiger.
It's the thrill of the tiger.
Rising up to the challenge of the tiger.
And the last known tiger stalks his prey in the night.
And he's watching us all with the eye...
...of the tiger.
Neil C.C.
Ergo.
The
eye of the tiger.
The eye of the tiger.
The house of the tiger.
Someone requested another song.
I think this one will be embarrassing if you're listening in public.
I might try the filter with this one.
I don't know if it's too much or not.
Baby, can't you see I'm calling?
A guy like you should wear a warning.
It's dangerous, I'm falling.
There's no escape, I can't wait.
I need a hit, baby give me it.
You're dangerous, I'm loving it.
Too high, can't come down.
Listen, my head's spinning round and round.
Do you feel me now?
With the taste of your lips, I wanna run.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
A taste of a poison paradise.
I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic?
And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic?
It's getting late to give you up.
I took a sip from the devil's cup.
Slowly, it's taking over me.
Too high, can't come down.
It's in the air and it's all around.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
A taste of a poison paradise.
I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic?
And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic?
Don't you know that you're toxic?
Taste of your lips, I'm on a run.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
A taste of a poison paradise.
I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic?
Taste of your lips, I'm on a run.
You're toxic, I'm slipping under.
A taste of a poison paradise.
I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic?
You're toxic in me now, but you're loving now.
I think I'm ready now.
That was toxic.
Toxic.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Too eroic.
I had to do something that would make everybody embarrassed if they're listening in public.
Too bad there's no erotic songs on here.
I've already checked before.
Actually, I don't know.
Did I search like this?
No, there is none.
Dang.
You proved that you can be ero.
Stop!
Boneless incoming.
Erotic songs are bangers too.
I know, right?
Do you guys know?
Apatou is pretty ero.
Is it actually?
Apatou, apatou, apatou, apatou.
I don't know it very well though.
That's the one with Bruno Mars and Lisa, right?
Oh, Rose.
Sorry.
Rose sings it.
I don't see it.
I see.
I told you, I don't know it.
I don't know it.
Apatou, apatou, apatou, apatou, apatou.
Anything by Sabrina Carpenter.
True!
Sabrina Carpenter.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
I don't know Juno, but I want to learn that one soon.
Can I request Neil Cicierega Lemon Demon?
Honestly, I don't know so many other Neil Cicierega ones.
Besides Boston.
I think I've done this one before though.
I'll sing this Sabrina Carpenter.
I think.
It's not me, I'm an I.O.
Is that sweet?
I guess so.
She can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Move it up, down, left, right, oh.
Switch it up like Nintendo.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
I can't relate to desperation.
My give-up bugs are on vacation.
And I got this one boy, and he won't stop calling.
When they act this way, I know I got him.
Too bad your ex didn't do it for ya.
Walked in a dream, came true before ya.
Soft skin and I perfumed it for ya.
I know a mountain do it for ya.
That morning coffee brewed it for ya.
One touch and I brand new it for ya.
Now he's...
Think about me every night, oh.
Isn't that sweet?
I guess so.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Move it up, down, left, right, oh.
Switch it up like Nintendo.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Holy shit.
Why'd she say that?
I guess so.
I'm working late.
Cause I'm a streamer.
Oh, he looks so cute.
Wrapped around my finger.
My twisted humor.
Make him laugh so often.
My honeybee.
Come and get this fallen.
Too bad your ex don't do it for ya.
Walked in a dream, came true before ya.
Soft skin and I perfumed it for ya.
I know a mountain do it for ya.
That morning coffee brewed it for ya.
One touch and I brand new it for ya.
Now he's...
thinking about me every night.
Oh, isn't that sweet?
I guess so.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Move it up, down, left, right, oh.
Switch it up like Nintendo.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Thinking about me every night.
Oh, isn't that sweet?
I guess so.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
Move it up, down, left, right, oh.
Switch it up like Nintendo.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know.
That's not me, espresso.
I'm now...
maybe...
obsessed with me...
right?
Maybe...
you're obsessed with me?
I'm working late.
Because I'm a streamer.
Espresso.
Sing Mirage by Kiowa.
So desu.
Is there a Mirage karaoke?
I wonder.
I can try.
Oh gosh.
I hope she's asleep.
Mirage.
Kiowa.
Instrumental.
Is there one?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Okay, lyrics.
Mirage, oh wait.
Kiowa.
Oh gosh, I feel like I'm gonna mess this up.
I'm sorry, Kiowa.
Make me up a new persona Calculated perfectly for you Pretending like it's all just for me But I think so, live life incognito Oh, I play God and I'm asking why You'll never see what I want, what I need Oh, do you?
No, no.
Oh, do you?
Follow through, let you pursue But now...
Tell me I'm a Mirage I told you up and... I told you up and down Wait, what to do with this mess Tell me the cost, it'd be good Play a part, my Mirage Mirage Oh no, wait.
I don't remember this part.
Everybody listen to the original, because it's better.
You'll never see what I want, what I need Oh, do you?
No, no.
Oh, do you?
Follow through, let you pursue But now...
Tell me I'm a Mirage I told you up and... I told you up and down Wait, what to do with this mess Tell me the cost, it'd be good Play a part, my Mirage Mirage
Let me feel you Sorry, I get so nervous when I sing these songs.
Tell me I'm a Mirage I told you up and...
I don't even know what to do with this mess Tell me the cost, it'd be good Play a part, my Mirage Mirage Mirage Spin the lights, the skies align On and on and on and on This Mirage, I'm lost Mirage Mirage
Yay, that was Mirage.
Kind of.
That was Mirage, kind of.
It's so different, like, listening to a song.
But, like, I never, I don't know, I only do the...
I only do the...
I never, like, sing along with it, I don't know.
I just listen to it.
Sounds like a hard song to sing live.
Yeah, there's a lot of overlapping parts, so...
I have to play Hot To Go.
Ok.
Why do you guys want me to sing Itch and the Borderline so much?
You guys aren't sick of that song?
5, 6, 5, 6, 7, 8
I don't want the world, but I'll take this city Who can play my girl?
Call me hot, not pretty Baby, do you like this beat?
I made it so you dance with me It's like 199 degrees When you're doing it with me, doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now, body roll Dance it out, you're hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now,
body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go When I woke up alone, staring at my ceiling I try not to care, but it hurts my feelings You don't have to stare, come here, get with it No one's touched me there in a damn hot minute Baby,
don't you like this beat?
I made it so you'd sleep with me It's like 199 degrees When you're doing it with me, doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now, body roll Dance it out, you're hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now,
body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go What's it take to get your heart down, babe?
What's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time for supper
H -O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hot to go It's hot in here.
Is anyone else hot?
Yay!
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Fine, I don't know that one H-O-T-T-O-G-O
Someone earlier requested...
I don't know, I feel like I'm being really silly tonight Doing serious songs seems...
It feels weird to do serious songs, I'm being too silly tonight It's because I did that song and it stuck in my head all the time?
I'm sorry I'm sorry
It's a silly night Fighting Dreamers!
We are Fighting Dreamers!
Fighting Dreamers!
Just go mad right now!
Right now!
We get it until you are sexy, you don't have to keep proving us wrong No, I don't think you believe that My beloved monster eels.
I don't know that one, I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry Did you say you knew one Anastasia song?
Yeah, that's what I was about to do But that's why I was just like, it feels weird to...
Anastasia Sing a serious song, you know I know a couple Anastasia songs
I like this song though, I'll do this one It's a little serious This is fine though Just fine
Heart, don't fail me now Courage, don't desert me Don't turn back now that we're here People always say Life is full of choices No one ever mentions fear Or how the world can seem so vast On a journey To the past
Somewhere down this road I know someone's waiting Years of dreams just can't be wrong Arms will open wide I'll be safe and want it finally, home where I belong.
Well, starting now, I'm learning fast on this journey to the past.
Family, there was once a time I must have had them too.
A family, I will never be complete until I find you.
One step at a time, one hope then another, who knows where this road may go.
Back to who I was, on to find my future, things my heart still needs to know.
Yes, let this be a sign, let this road be mine.
Let it lead me to my past, and bring me home.
Sorry, I couldn't...
That was from Anastasia.
Journey to the past.
You're a sinner.
Do you know what emergence vibe from IMAS?
I don't think I do.
Last surprise from P5.
I've never played P5.
I'm sorry, I always feel bad when you guys super chat songs.
I don't know them.
All that jazz.
And all that jazz.
What was that?
Journey to the past.
Wait, journey to the past.
Past.
Look at the membership!
Thank you.
Fine, I'll do this since so many people are like, please.
Before I forget.
Oh, this one.
I don't know this one.
I
don't know this one.
I don't know this one.
I don't know
this one.
I
don't know what happened.
For some reason, I couldn't hear myself singing this song.
Like my... I don't know.
What's it called?
It got all weird.
My monitor.
So if I sounded bad, I'm really sorry.
Couldn't hear myself.
Consider Ikenai Butterline and Snake Eater your signature songs.
I don't think I'm the only one.
No way, really?
Ikenai Butterline.
I'm gonna give a... If you're listening from the convention.
Rather, if you're going to the concert.
I'm giving a little hint for a song that Doki and I are singing tomorrow.
There's a part in it.
Where you guys have to yell.
But I don't think it's a super well-known song.
So I don't want to say what the song is.
But basically, I think you can follow along pretty easily.
Because, you know, we also recorded backing for it.
So...
I'm just... If you're listening.
I don't know.
Maybe I should've... I talked about it too with her.
I was just like, we should probably tell people.
At least with this part, since there's like a...
So basically, you'll just go, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's really easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's it.
So, you know.
If you're there, maybe go see it.
But if not...
If not, then there's a karaoke right now.
Yippee!
I think you guys can follow along if you heard it.
Don't worry.
Can you do For Good from Wicked?
That's such a sad song, but I'll do it.
Such a sad song.
Why are you making me sing sad things?
Wait.
Okay, here we go.
This song makes me tear up.
Wait, whose part?
I gotta switch parts, I think.
Girlfriend by Avril Lavigne.
I'll sing that one.
I'm limited.
Just look at me.
And just look at you.
You can do all I couldn't do.
Good enough.
So now it's up to you.
For the both of us.
Now it's up to you.
I've heard it said That people come into our lives for a reason Bringing something we must learn And we are led To those who help us most to grow If we let them Then we help them in return Well, I don't know if I believe that's true But I know I'm who I am today Because I knew you Like a comet pulled from orbit As it passes the sun Like a stream that meets a boulder Halfway through the woods Who can say if I've been changed for the better?
Cause I knew you I have been changed for good
And well maybe That we will never meet again In this lifetime So let me say before we part So much of me Is made of what I learned from you You'll be with me Like a handprint on my heart And now, whatever way our stories end I know you have rewritten mine By being my friend Like a ship blown from its mooring By a wind off the sea Like a seed dropped by a skybird In a distant wood Who can say if I've been changed for the better But,
because I knew you Because I knew you I have been changed for good And just to clear the air I ask forgiveness For the things I've done you blamed me for But then I guess we know there's blame to share And none of it seems to matter anymore Like a comet pulled from mooring As it passes the sun Like a stream that meets a boulder Halfway through the wood Who can say if I've been changed for the better?
I do believe I have been changed for the better.
And because I knew you...
Because I knew you...
I have been changed...
For...
For good.
I couldn't remember which harmony part it is.
I couldn't remember.
Yay!
That was for good.
I'm not okay after that.
For good.
Sad song.
Crying in the club.
You sound way better than the green one.
What do you mean by that?
I'll do a couple more.
I should rest my throat a little bit.
Itai my kokoro.
Someone requested something and I don't remember what.
God knows?
Why are there so many god knows?
Fine, fine, fine.
I need the background.
I can do this one.
I think that one will get flagged.
This is fine, probably.
Ah!
Zenaka mukete satashimau ano lonely rain Watashi wo tsuiteiku yo donna tsurai sekai no yami no naka de sae Kitto anata wo kagayaite Koeru mirai no hate yowasa yue ni tamashii kowasareru you ni Kasanaru yo ima futari ni god bless
Tokashite samayou
Semete utsukushii yume dake wo Egakinagara oikakeyou for your lonely heart Stop it!
Lies aren't like you.
Look into my eyes.
This is who I am.
I, I, I, I, I!
In the future, when I get stronger, I might be able to change my fate.
My wish, I want to make it come true, but everything is God knows.
You are here, you are here, but the other people have disappeared.
I will follow you, no matter how painful the darkness of the world is.
Surely, you will shine.
To the end of the future, so that my soul won't be destroyed by my weakness, my way, I will overlap now.
God bless us both.
Yay,
that was God knows.
I tried to...
I tried to do calls for songs to help you guys learn how and when to like, you know, insert call, insert, you know, and do, you know, because it's like, it can be kind of like, silly to remember, you know, I mean, even I, you know, I've been doing this for like,
10 plus years, and even I still make mistakes sometimes, you know, it's, my hope for you guys is to, and I've been thinking about this as of lately, you know, because a lot of more people I've seen, so many people getting into, into otage, and getting into...
No, thank you for that!
Getting, getting into otage and getting into doing mix and all that fun stuff.
And, you know, the one thing always to remember is it's not, it doesn't have to be so clean, you know, don't forget why you're doing otage, don't just do it to do it, you have to do it because it comes from your soul, you know, otage and mix, it sounds ugly,
that's why you hear the guys being like, because it's supposed to, I always say, unleash the yakai in your soul, you know, because it's supposed to come from your actual gut, you're supposed to feel like you are so excited to support favorite idol, your favorite,
like, singer, favorite, you know, whoever, favorite, um, like, you know, I guess, I guess singer or idol really kind of, kind of, but you know what I mean, your favorite talent, so that you can't help but literally like scream, that's where, that's where the mix comes from,
that's where it comes from, so don't ever forget that, don't ever forget why, you know, the oen dan, where the otage comes from, the otage is not just to spin your pen lights around, it's supposed to be, you know, to truly, truly, you know, support the idol,
I kind of, you know, don't want things to get lost in the sauce a little bit, maybe it's just because I'm an old school ota, maybe it's because I'm an old school ota, how am I gatekeeping?
What the fuck?
I'm literally teaching people how to do calls.
Oh, is that a rainbow?
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you, dude!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
But, you know, I went to an idol show not too long ago, and I don't know, calls and stuff have evolved, it's kind of, I've been talking to my friends recently about it, about how, like, the western sphere has kind of made their old, like, ota culture,
it's kind of crazy, but I'm old school, so, I'm old school, I've been doing it for so long, like, I know the old stuff, but everything has moved so beyond me.
I'm a boomer!
People hating need to realize you don't need to be perfect and buy the book.
Yeah, exactly!
It's supposed to come from your soul.
It's supposed to come from, you know,
inside you.
Don't forget that, okay?
Don't forget why you're screaming at a show, okay?
Don't just scream, the mix, just scream!
Remember why!
Remember why you're screaming.
Use code BOOMER at checkout!
Why, VTuber?
Not screaming for the sake of screaming.
That's why it sounds so ugly.
That's why it's like, you should make some mix videos to help educate us.
Someone has asked me before, but I should.
I should.
But again, I don't know.
It's also, you know, beat counts and stuff too.
There is an art to it.
But again, I don't want people to be scared from it.
I think it's fun.
It's very fun to learn.
Honestly, you know, it's electrifying when you're in a room and everybody is doing all the mix together and everything.
And you feel like you're truly bonded.
But you're truly bonded because, you know, you are there to support, you know, the idol or the singer.
What if people are scared of me doing it?
That's good.
Unleash the yakai in your soul.
They should be scared.
I was scared that my idol would think that I was scary doing mix, but then she called me an angel and I was like, no, I'm a ghost.
I'm a ghost.
It's so funny.
If you want to hear how much I love mix and how much I love doing otage and everything, I love it so much with a passion.
I love chikage, which is like kind of the dumber waza that you can do.
Sorry, I'm kind of nerding out a little bit.
But I love it so much that there was an idol group that I used to so much love.
I love them so much.
Their fans were absolutely crazy.
They were, they were some of the like, they were, they were so, they would get so yakai and it was so much fun and going to their lives was just like a huge party.
And then my oshi did graduate and I was sad about that, but I was still following the group because I really liked them.
And then there was this one girl who had joined.
She was, she was a newer member.
And one day she talked about, she, she posted a tweet that was just like, man, I hate when people yell too loud at our shows and you can't hear us singing.
What's the point?
And I was like, I got so mad.
I got so mad I stopped supporting.
I got so mad.
I was just like, what do you mean?
You joined this group.
You joined this group and you knew that you were going to go and say that?
I was so angry.
Because I want to be able to, I want to be able to, but also, I don't know.
It's been, it's been so weird.
Like now you have groups like iLife that basically feed you.
It feels a little too manufactured.
Like I like them.
They're so cute.
I love Aisu.
But they feed you the calls.
So there's probably some people listening who are like, I don't know what the hell you're, any two words you're saying right now, Minto.
I'm so sorry.
Hold on.
I just gotta, I just gotta say things real quick.
But it feels like a little too, like, manufactured, too force fed.
I don't want, I don't want my calls to be force fed to me.
Like the fun part about calls is, I mean, not to say that I've done this before.
But you, like, basically, after like an idol releases a song or whatever, they'll go to dinner, they'll do like their own afk and then they will, and then they'll like come up with calls for, for that song.
And it comes from the fans.
So, you know, when it's, when it's not coming from the fans, it feels like a little too, too corporate.
So I'm just like...
Oh, I want, I want, I want it to be a good, fun thing for everybody.
That's all.
And you think that's a boomer take?
I don't know.
Actually, really, in Japan, like mix is kind of a dying art in some circles.
Because after the pandemic, people just stopped mixing.
And I think it's so sad.
Because it's like one of the things I love the most about going to idol shows.
It's what makes idol shows so uniquely the way that they are because of the way that fans have this special culture around it.
So, yeah, not to say that it's completely dead or anything, but you know, it's...
So that's why having this revival, or like the surge, I guess, in the West, it's not a revival, really.
It's like the surge of people mixing in the West is so crazy to me.
Should songs be written with calls in mind?
I wouldn't say...
Not always, but I like songs that way.
I like songs that way.
I think it's fun.
Blame me for that.
Blame me for what?
What did I do?
What are you blaming me for?
What are we blaming Minto for?
No!
Hold on, my chat broke.
Sorry for ranting a little bit.
Thought I get revival?
Nah, I didn't do anything.
I didn't do anything.
I just did what I like to do and then people found it.
Hmm.
I learned a lot about idol culture from you.
I'm so glad!
It's such a fun and unique world.
Truly.
Truly, truly, truly.
Love it so much.
Okay, why shall we sing?
Give me a suggestion.
Astro Bot.
I am Astro Bot.
I'm going to sing maybe three more songs.
We'll go to 20.
Fans voting.
I learned it from you Minto.
I learned it from you.
I love sharing about the culture.
I love you sharing about the culture.
Thanks!
Can you do Everlasting Guilty Crown by Egoist?
I don't know and I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, sorry, sorry.
I don't know what I want to do.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll try that one next time.
Another song with calls.
What would be a good song with calls?
I could just do the calls.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh wait!
Someone asked me to sing this one earlier.
I'll sing this one.
I don't know.
Right here!
Right now!
That's right!
Fighting Dreamers!
Right
here!
Right now!
Yay!
That was cool!
By Flo!
It's my first time in Atlanta!
Can't wait to see you tomorrow!
See you tomorrow!
What's that from?
Magical Cure Love Shop Miku.
I only know the one part.
Now it's time for the moment you've been waiting for!
One, two...
Ready?
Miku Miku Piiiii!
Keep going!
Piiiii!
Thanks for the karaoke Minto!
Helps fight the concert FOMO while I explore Akiba!
What do you mean?
Why would you have concert FOMO if you are in Akiba?
I want to switch spots with you.
Nozomi!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Akiba guide where?
Oh, you can just search my video.
I did an Akiba tour.
Someone requested something.
Wait, hold on.
It made me think of something else.
Minto Minto Miiii!
Enjoy the concert Minto!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
What's the dress code for tomorrow night?
Birthday suit.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh, that's what...hold on.
Hold on.
What's it called?
I saw someone's eye.
There it is.
That's the anime.
Virtual!
Thanks for the gifted!
Please fire a beam at me and free me from this Mortal Kombat coil.
Are you okay?
Oh no, this is not the one I want to do.
Here we go.
This is the one I wanted.
I think someone requested this one earlier.
If I got it wrong, I'm so sorry.
Someone requested maybe this song.
Maybe.
Here we go.
Feels
good!
Don't scout me.
If you don't think so, let's destroy everything.
It's the moon.
If your eyes dry up, you won't be able to sleep well.
Let's go!
It's so
exciting!
Madness!
You wanna madness!
If you call me, I'll be more intense and more exciting.
Madness!
If you call me, it'll be the end.
Gay horse!
Is it really gay horse?
I mean, maybe.
Thank you for the super!
Got here just in time to hear my wife's song.
That was...
Let me put my mic down for this.
I've been holding it this whole time.
Let's...
Snake eater?
OK, I'll do snake eater.
I haven't done it in a minute.
Is that true?
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know, but... I don't know actually.
I don't know.
This one.
And I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
I give my life.
Not for order.
Snake eater!
In my time.
There'll be no one else.
Crime.
It's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eater.
I give my life.
And someday you'll go through the rain.
And someday you'll feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal, that trial to survive.
For the day we see new light.
I give my
life.
Snake eater.
In my time.
There'll be no one else.
Crime.
It's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eater.
Snake, snake, snake, snake, snake, snake.
Eater.
Snake eater.
Last song, everybody.
Last song.
Shadow Cross!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
And KM!
Can't go to concert due to geographic impairment, but wish you two luck.
And happy birthday, KM!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear KM.
Happy birthday, sorry if I get sleepy.
I'm glad that I feel calmed down from the cabin stream.
Wait,
hold on.
What did you say?
OK.
Marry on a cross?
Oh gosh, I don't know if my voice can do it.
Haven't done that song in a long time.
I do like that song.
Silver Wraith!
I'll be at a different concert.
Sonic Symphony when you're having yours.
OK.
Have fun, I guess.
No, I'm just kidding.
Thank you for all the good times you've given me.
I hope you have all the time of your lives at FTR.
And our after lives.
I guess since I haven't done this one in a while, but I want to change the...
Maybe it's a kind of fun song to end on.
Let me change the pitch.
Maybe the key can go up two.
Or four.
Let me try a four.
It's gonna sound like a chipmunk.
But through all the sorrow, we've been riding high And the truth of the matter is, I'll never let you go, let you go We were scanning the cities, walking to greater dues But besides all the glamour, all we got was bruise But through all the sorrow, we've earned
what the matter is I'll never let you go, let you go
You go and tell the psychotic Mary across Not just another bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross If you choose to run away with me I will tingle you eternally And I see nothing wrong with that Guys, I think I messed up with the pitch.
I think it's...
Uh-oh.
I don't know why I always mess up with the pitch on this song.
Oh gosh.
Oh god.
Uh-oh.
I think I'm in trouble.
We were searching for reasons to play by the rule But we quickly found out it was just for fools Not for all the sorrow, we'll be riding high And the truth of the matter is, I'll never let you go, let you go
I'm scared I'm scared You go down just like holy Mary across
Not just another bloody Mary,
Mariana You go down just like holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross Your beauty never ever scared me, Mariana, Mariana Cross If you choose to run away with me, I will tingle you eternally And I see nothing wrong with that I
can't go higher Nothing wrong with that
Nothing wrong with that
Yay!
Sorry for butchering it.
Sorry!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for the karaoke!
Hopefully, I'll see you now with this, plus this other stream from today that makes up for 3 hours.
My quota.
Yay!
Be fun to do an album, listen along to some of Neil C.
Cierga's music There was one time I did a road trip and we just listened to Neil C.
Cierga's album the entire time Of course, Bustin' and Eye of the Tiger are my favorites.
Those are the only two I can remember It's the Eye of the Tiger, it's the thrill of the tiger Nora Ika!
Thank you for the 20 gifted, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you For those who can't be at the concert
For those who will be going to the concert, thank you so much!
We really really appreciate it Doki and I are nervous as heck, but...
It's gonna be a really fun show, the setlist is really really fun and really goofy And I think a good mix of fun stuff and silly stuff So I think you guys will really really love it And if you guys can't go, I'll always be working hard to hopefully have more opportunities like this in the future So that I can hopefully come to you one day!
And if you're just like, I can't, I can't get out of this city, Minto I can't leave this city One day I'll come to your city, one day, hopefully, I'll do my best to reach many many places all over!
So, yeah, and we will be uploading some of the concert To YouTube, to my channel, and also people will be recording, so Of course, since you are a wisp, you are there in spirit!
Wink
wonk!
See you!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you Let's see, is there anybody we can raid?
Anybody streaming right now?
I wonder if it'll let me raid
Let's see
Let me try
Oh yeah, ok
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
See you!